[Music]
with the midterm elections approaching
suddenly everyone's admitting that
surgical mass actually don't stop the
coronavirus if they did maybe close to a
million americans wouldn't have died
from it
even joe biden and nancy pelosi have
stopped pretending but some schools
haven't gotten the memo they're still
forcing kids to wear masks
no excuse on wednesday florida governor
ron desantis was in tampa for a press
conference at the university of south
florida as he came to the podium he saw
several students wearing masks here's
what he said you do not have to wear
those masks i mean please take it off
honestly it's not doing anything and we
got to stop with this theater so you
want to wear it fine but this is this is
ridiculous
well it is ridiculous and if no one else
is going to tell him probably good he
told them it's not good to lie to kids
at best it makes them grow up to be
liars
and of course as you may have noticed
that enraged the media they were totally
infuriated by this because it refuted
the lies that they have told for years
about children being forced to wear
masks so here's how they reacted to what
desantis said
republican governor of florida today ron
desantis berating high school kids for
wearing masks at his indoor news
conference why lord where was that guy
raised so mean
i mean serious no i'm serious was that
guy raised in a barn and seriously this
is
this is a question i asked who
raised him
this is the governor of your state and
it's televised like you're on video it's
going to go everywhere these kids are at
an age where people already tease and
bully and like now you just you saw that
girl like scrambling to take hers off
like what do i do i i just found to say
that to a bunch of
miners one kid looked at them like shut
up yeah i like that there were some kids
that did not take off their mass and i
thought that's damn good parenting right
there
oh they're such liars they'll say
anything and if they think you're
gaining momentum
they want to crush you so just to be
clear
telling kids they don't actually have to
wear masks because masks don't work is
bullying but threatening to throw them
out of school and destroy their lives if
they don't wear a mask
is science
we want to straighten this out with the
governor of florida himself we are
honored to be joined by ron desantis
governor thanks for coming on um
so why did you say that good evening
well tucker none of the adults were
wearing masks and it seemed to me that
someone told those kids they had to do
it so i just wanted to make it very
clear they do not need to be doing it
obviously in florida it's a free state
you can do it but i think it's also
important to point out that there's no
reason to do it for for young and
healthy kids especially in the state of
florida we never had a mass mandate of
course but our guidance from our health
department is not to wear these cloth
masks and i think it needs to be said
because people have been lied to for two
years and so i was uh i didn't want it
to be thinking that like they were told
to do this by me because i certainly
wouldn't do that and you know they talk
about oh by letting someone have a
choice to take off their mask and
welcoming that choice that that's
somehow bullying tucker bullying is
locking kids out of school which they
did bullying is forcing kids to wear
masks for eight hours a day which they
did for two years and are only stopping
now because the pollings change
bullying is kicking people out of work
because of vaccine mandates we fought
all of those policies in florida we
lifted people up and we liberated them
from local school boards and governments
that imposed them
it's a little weird to hear criticism
from people who are unmasked sitting in
crowded studios
saying that you're immoral for telling
kids who are at a lower risk than the
adults who are unmasked in the studios
not to wear masks like what people can't
see themselves i guess
well ann it creates a two-tier society
you have adults that are not masks
and then the students are all masked or
you'll have a crowded restaurant where
everyone's having a good time and they
make the servers wear mass i reject the
two-tier society i say every time we go
if we're at a big event and the servers
are wearing it they should be liberated
from those masks it is political theater
they're doing it for the appearance
they're not doing it because it's having
any meaningful medical impact no but
everyone loves a caste system especially
when they're at the top of it right i
mean that's really what they're
demanding
exactly and we've seen time and time
again all these left-wing lockdown
politicians they'll impose mandates on
others then they'll be out cavorting and
by the way they escape to florida and
live under our freedom time and time
again and we've documented that as well
so it is a hierarchy and that's what
they're trying to impose and we reject
that in florida and yes if i have people
that i think are being bullied into
doing mass i'm going to let them know
you have the right to take it off and
i'm also going to tell them the truth
which not a lot of adults have told them
that it's not effective to wear them in
the first place amen cover your face
servant that's exactly right governor
ron desantis of the free state of
florida great to see you tonight thank
you